instead of the Manila skyline these
Filipino cadets will soon be seeing
plenty of this view the sea and a ship's
wake
they'll be on the ocean for months on
end and can't wait to set sail I love
the sea very much it helps me to refresh
when I see when I see the sea every
morning every side rice and you know as
I know it's it's actually dog the thing
that makes that makes my career moving
for the time being that movement means
marching in formation just after sunrise
each morning it's part of life at the
Marine Academy of Asia and the Pacific
one of many colleges in the Philippines
serving the shipping industry bien Carla
Gallup owned now in his fourth year has
no problem with the ritual on board ship
that's one of the vital things and
character that we should have prior
prior to the concrete situation of
having life on board ship we are built
we will be dealing with lots of people
you should know how to respect them and
that respect is crucial on the bridge
especially in turbulent conditions
hurricanes on the high seas can mean 15
meter waves and minimal visibility
everyone plays an integral role and must
pull together in calm or rough seas this
high-tech simulator gives budding
sailors a taste of what to expect some
1,800 students are enrolled in the
Academy in a country that produces more
sailors than any other that's not
surprising the Philippines comprise more
than 7,000 islands the country has a
strong seafaring tradition
if Filipinos moved from one island to
another they use boats and and so
they're used to the sea they use the big
waves we have 26 typhoons every year so
here used to that but I guess more
importantly also that it provides the
seafaring career provides a very good
livelihood for them that's tempting talk
in a country where 60% of the population
live below the poverty line becoming a
sailor offers a way out from those bleak
prospects the capital Manila is a magnet
for those hoping for a job at sea
there's no shortage of Filipinos willing
to invest time and money to boost their
prospects this school specializing in
cruise ship staff is one of many in the
country among the skills taught here is
how to cater to and for discriminating
crews guests and how those passengers
expect their rooms to look
laney Ramirez has five minutes to get
the bed into pristine condition I'm
sorry the course she's taking lasts five
months she hopes it will be a sound
investment not least because it's
costing her families several months
wages but it's likely she'll end up
earning enough to support them making
the sweat and toil now worth it max they
say is a major training center and
supplier of seafarers to the
International Cruise Lines the sector's
growing rapidly as is the need for
well-trained Filipino personnel because
we are by nature service-oriented
smiling is a very natural for us so I
would say yes we do we do provide a lot
of skill human resource all over the
world
filipino sailors are indeed in high
demand for their skills and for their
lower cost they may end up working on
ships for major European companies but
most are signed up to Filipino agencies
which means Filipino terms and
conditions max a say is the biggest
crewing agency in the country and never
short of applicants
back at the Maritime Academy en Carla
Gallup own has no worries about agencies
and being underpaid his training here is
being covered by a Japanese shipping
company in exchange for a five-year
commitment to the firm after graduation
he'll begin as third officer there are
other prestigious maritime colleges in
the Philippines but this is probably the
only one run by a trade union the
associated marine officers and seaman's
union of the Philippines also functions
as a welfare and relief organization for
its members the Union even runs its own
hospital in Manila offering free
treatment for sailors and their families
they find talk of budget sailors from
the Philippines annoying and offensive
you follow European standards we follow
Asian standards no I mean the cost of
living there is totally different from
the cost of living here if a Filipino
would live in Germany or somewhere in
Europe then probably he has to earn
European wages otherwise he will die
earning Filipino wages no I mean local
wages no because the standards here are
different
the union also has a dedicated village
home to 530 families of officers and
engineers they lead a relatively
privileged life here the hope is that
the settlement will inspire more
villages as on most days the Cultural
Center is an all-women affair most of
the sailors themselves are out on
six-month deployments the bitter price
of a career at sea yes I always think of
that the b-team always sad but you don't
have a job here we have to stay in the
ship to work
bien Carla Gallup own wants to start his
own family - at some point for now he's
happy to be sailing the Seas and hopes
his career horizon will at some point
see him making the grade as captain
you